a defining moment for northern ireland
those are the words of shin fame leader
michelle o'neill describing her party's
historic result in local elections the
irish nationalist party whose mission is
to unite ireland won the largest share
of votes in the british province for the
first time ever o'neill is on course to
lead the next government she said it was
time for a healthy debate on moving
towards a united ireland
well ireland was divided a century ago
after its war of independence against
britain what's now the republic emerged
as a separate nation but now northern
ireland remained part of the united
kingdom because its protestant majority
wanted to stay british
roman catholics never accepted this
partition
tension between the two communities
turned violent in the 1960s only ending
in 1998 with the good friday agreement
but brexit has sparked new tensions
northern ireland left the european union
with the rest of the uk while the
republic of ireland remains a member
well let's get the latest from dw's
charlotte chelsea pill in london so
charlotte shin fein is set to get its
first win in northern ireland what does
this mean for the country
well that would indeed be an absolute
watershed moment for politics in
northern ireland as you say shin fein
are on track to become the largest party
and therefore uh be entitled to the post
of first minister for the first time
ever now that really would be
a historic moment in northern ireland
now you mentioned there the fact that
they are committed to this idea of a
united island that's certainly the issue
that is going to grab the headlines the
prospect of that not imminent there is a
lot that stands in the way but certainly
this uh a win would open the door to
that prospect so many are watching very
closely but there are also issues in the
short term that need to be considered a
lot of uncertainty perhaps instability
could be coming down the tracks in the
week ahead and that is uh partly because
under the terms of the good friday peace
agreement of 1998 northern ireland has a
power sharing government what that means
in essence is the democratic unionist
party needs to agree to form a
government uh with shin fein going
forward that is something that they've
said they're going to find very
difficult the reason that they've given
is what's called the northern ireland
protocol that's a an agreement that
formed was was formed after brexit to
avoid a hard border on the island of
ireland but what it essentially means is
there is a trade border in the irish sea
between great britain and northern
ireland so that's something that is
likely to make the headlines once again
over the next couple of weeks okay so
some uk lawmakers are downplaying the
significance of a sinn fein win let's
listen to this
as for the question of the constitution
i mean that's a lower order priority not
just for sinn fein but the 30 percent of
people in northern ireland who support
border pole i mean the majority of
people i think won't just just want to
see their government in northern ireland
back up and running
so wilshin feign pursue its goal of a
united ireland even though it wasn't a
priority in their election
it wasn't a priority they were focused
on more bread and butter issues now
they've said that they are not fixated
on a date for any sort of a referendum
and certainly it isn't imminent but
their stated intentions are clear now
that doesn't mean to say that this vote
is a reflection of the big public uh
support for that if anything it's not so
much that sinn fein has made gains it's
more that there's been a a divider
fractured
unionist uh vote that is the issue so
it's not likely that we are going to see
that uh in the near future certainly but
this does open the door to it all right
charlotte chelsea pill in london for us
thank you so much